les violences sont arrivées depuis deux
semaines au Soudan du Sud ce pays qui
est indépendant du Soudan depuis 2011
sort lui-même à peine d'une guerre
civile et d'une famille ce jeune de 17
ans compare la situation dans son pays à
une jungle
a obligé à venir ici dit-il il n'y a
rien de bon dans mon pays c'est le chaos
n'importe qui peut voler vos biens
depuis du conflit les entreprises entre
ils ont pu fuir Mubarak Hussen est
arrivé au Canada avec sa femme et ses
enfants le 24 mars dernier mais ses
parents ses frères et sa soeurs sont
encore au soudains son frère aîné a
finalement pu quitter la capitale
cartoon dimanche elle a été arrêtée on
l'avait volé l'argent sur la route pour
aller à des bandits
libérés des prisons souvent nous sommes
profondément attristés par ce qui se
passe dans notre pays
or soudain la ville portuaire sur le
bord de la mer Rouge accueille de plus
en plus de soudaine et qui fuient les
violences les combats se propagent
maintenant dans plusieurs villes
mais les bombes n'empêchent pas ces
citoyens de manifester leur colère
on refuse de rester silencieux dit-il
c'est notre droit de parler pour contrer
la voix des combattants qui n'ont aucune
intégrité comme Unity ce groupe conteste
la légitimité du général émetti et de
ses hommes les forces de soutien rapides
un des deux gros armés qui s'affrontent
depuis la mi-avril
ces combattants proviennent d'une
ancienne milice créée lors de la guerre
au Darfour une province du Soudan qui
s'était battue pour son indépendance
dans les années 2000 j'ai peur aussi à
ma sœur
à Montréal
famille
ou qu'il l'a élevé ses frères et ses
soeurs pourraient être tué n'importe
quand parce qu'il sait de quoi est
capable les métiers lui et ses hommes
avaient été recrutés par l'ancien
dictateur
Omar El Bechir pour commettre des
massacres au Darfour pour qu'il puisse
faire des choses que l'armée régulière
ne peuvent pas le faire c'est de par
exemple faire de massacre tuer les gens
des innocents des villages ou complet
qui était massacrés des femmes c'était
comme
violé et ils font ils font des choses
pires puis on craint que ça arrive à
cartoon aussi
2015 avec sa femme qui est
épidémiologiste ils ont trois filles nés
ici c'est une belle journée à l'école
aussi très inquiète pour ses proches au
Soudan plusieurs sont toujours à cartoon
après la révolte populaire de 2019 qui
avait fait tomber au Marvel Béchir elle
et son mari avait rêvé de démocratie et
de retourner au Soudan on avait hâte de
voir un gouvernement démocratique mais
maintenant on cherche la paie en fait
les gens et vivre la peur tout le temps
puis si ça on va maintenant just la paix
j'aimerais bien aller puis développer le
pays le Soudan pour que comme aider les
gens
soigner les gens comme j'avais cette
intention mais
c'est plus là
la guerre
de tout le monde ici Sophie Langlois
Radio-Canada Montréal